صاحب السمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان بن عبد
الله ال سعود وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
اصحاب السمو المعالي الوزراء السيدات
والساده اسمحوا لي في البدايه ان اتقدم
بالشكر لمعالي السيد احمد عطاف وزير
الشؤون الخارجيه والجاليه الوطنيه بالخارج
للجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
الذي ارحب به عضو جديدا في مجلسنا وابارك
له على تولي مسؤولياته متمنيا لها كل
التوفيق
تقدم له بالشكر على ترقص بلاده اعمال
القمه العربيه العاديه للعام 2022
بالجزائر والتي كانت قمه ناجحه بكل
المقاييس من حيث تنظمها واعمالها
وقراراتها كما تقدم لكم
بالشكر صاحب السمو امير فيصل بن فرحان على
حسن الاعداد والاستقبال وكرم الضيافه الذي
احطتنا به المملكه العربيه السعوديه منذ
وصولنا الى هذه الاراضي المقدسه
متمنيا لاعمال القمه كل النجاح والتوفيق
باذن الله
وارحب في مجلسنا بالدكتور العزيز الصديق
فيصل المقداد وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه
واتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا لمقعدها
مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي
حضور الكريم
مرت المنطقه العربيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
ومنذ انعقاد قمه الجزائر في نوفمبر الماضي
بعدد من بعدد من الاحداث والتطورات التي
تستحق التوقف عندها
وربما كان
من حسن الطالع ان تنعقد قمتان عربيتان في
اقل من عاما في هذه الظروف التي اقل ما
يقال في وصفها انها استثنائيه وضاغطه
فما زالت البيئه العالميه حافله بالمخاطر
والازمات
بعض هذه الازمات لم تشهد الساحه الدوليه
لها مثيلا منذ عقود طويله وقد امتدت
اثاراتها
اثارها وتبعاتها الى كل بقعه في العالم
تقريبا
مخلفه مخاوف جمه وحاله خطيره من انعدام
اليقين
ان صراع القوه الكبرى التي تمثل الحرب في
اوكرانيا واحده من حلقاتها
تخصم من الامن العالمي
وتشيع الاضطراب في الاقتصاد الدولي
وتضع على كاهل الكثير من الدول تكاليف
اضافيه
سواء في تعزيز الامن او في الحصول على
الموارد لا سيما الطاقه والغزاء
ويقيني ان هذه السرعه الصراعات تمثل تطورا
سلبيا خاصه على الدول البازغه الساعيه الى
النمو
والاسواق الناشئه التي تحتاج للاستقرار
ومن بينها الكثير من دول منطقتنا العربيه
واظن ان علينا الاستمرار في التحرك والعمل
ككتله موحده
تنسق في المواقف وتتحدث بلسان واحد فهذا
ما يعطي
مواقفنا ثقلا ويمنحها وزنا ويوفر المظله
الحاميه لمنطقتنا من شرور الاستقطاب
والصراع في قمه النظام الدولي
الصوره في المنطقه العربيه خلال الشهود
الشهور الماضيه مختلطه
تحمل بعض المؤشرات المطمئنه جنبا الى جنب
مع مخاطر جديده تثير القلق الشديد
في السودان
وللاسف اندلع نزاع مسلح شاهدنا جميعا مدى
خطورته
خطراته على شعب السودان الذي روع ابنائه
وواجهه الموت والتشريد جراء صراع لم
يتسببوا فيه
وخطورته على الدوله السودانيه
واستقرارها ووحدتها الترابيه وسلامه
مؤسساتها الوطنيه
السودان بلد عربي مهم
واشتعال الصراع العسكري في مدنه وشوارعه
على هذا النحو المؤسف ادنى قلوب العرب
واننا نعتبر قمه جده فرصه يتعينوا
اغتنامها من اجل وضع حدا لكافه المظاهر
المسلحه
كخطوه اولى نحو استعاده الهدوء والعوده
لمسار السياسه
واقول هنا ان العرب لن يتركوا اخوانهم في
السودان وحدهم فنحن نواكب التطورات ونقدم
كل الدعم الممكن وقد شكل مجلسكم الموقر
مجموعه اتصالا لهذا الغرض في السابع من
هذا الشهر
وراينا جهدا كبيرا محموما متواصلا للوساطه
قامت به المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هنا في جده
ولكن الامر مرهونا في المحصله باراده
السودانيين
وقياداتهم لوضع حد لهذا الانحدار
واسكات البنادق في اسرع وقت
وبرغم ان الازمات في سوريا واليمن وليبيا
ما زالت قائمه من دون حل شامل او تسويه
النهائيه
الا انها تمر بمرحله من الجمود التي تسمح
بمقاربات جديده
وقد حدث بالفعل تحريك للمياه الراكده في
عدد من هذه الازمات
واتخذ مجلسكم الموقر قرارا في سبعه مايو
حول سوريا انطوى على مقاربه شامله للازمه
ومهدت الطريق لانخراطا عربيا اكبر واكثر
فاعليه في تعزيز التسويه
ومعالجه التبعات والاثار التي لحقت بسوريا
ودول الكبار في السنوات الماضيه
ان سوريا دوله لها اسهام حضاري بارز في
هذه المنطقه على مر تاريخها وهي دوله
مؤسسه مؤسسه في هذه الجامعه
واننا جميعا نتطلع لتفاعل سوري بناء
وايجابي مع هذه الحراك العربي لصالح شعبها
وتعزيزا لدورها وحضورها
سياده الرئيس
سمو الامير
نلمسه بعض التطورات الايجابيه في مواقف
دول الكبار وادارتها لعلاقاتها مع المنطقه
العربيه
اتحدث هنا عن ايران وتركيا على وجه
التحديد
وليس خافيا معانته المنطقه العربيه ولا
زالت من الاثار السلبيه الخطيره للتدخل في
شؤونها الداخليه
اننا ننشر علاقات تقوم على الاحترام
المتبادل ومبدا السياده وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول من هذا المنطلق
اعاود في هذا المقام الترحيب بالاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه في بيجين
بمبادره مشكوره ومحموده من الرئيس الصيني
ونتطلع الى ان يمثلوا هذا الاتفاق خطوه
حاسمه لحل الخلافات
والنزاع والنزاعات الاقليميه بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه وان يؤسس لعلاقه جديده قوامها
حسن الجوار واحترام السياده والالتزام
بمبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
الناظمه للعلاقات بين الدول
السيد الرئيس الوضع في الاراضي المحتله
وفلسطين يقتربوا من مرحله الانفجار
نعرف جميعا ان استمرار الاحتلال واغلاق
الطريق امام التسويه التي تسمح بانهاء
الصراع واقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه هي
الاسباب الرئيسيه والجذريه لما يعانيه
اخواننا في فلسطين
ولكن زاد على هذه المعاناه في الشهور
الاخيره
عامل جديد يتمثل في حكومه اليمين
الاسرائيلي التي تباشر سياسه بالغه التطرف
والتهور ادت الى زياده منسوب العمق منذ
بدايه العام الحالي على نحو بالغ الخطوره
وينظر بما هو اسوا
اننا نشدد على ان مبادره السلام العربيه
بكافه عناصرها
تظل الخيار الاستراتيجي الاول لانهاء
الاحتلال
ونحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه عن
هذا التطور التدهور الخطير في الوضع
ونؤكد ان ممارساتها المنفلته
ونهجها المتطرف
سينعكس من دون شك على التعامل العربي معها
وفق محددات مبادره السلام العربيه
والفلسفه الحاكمه لها
ان هذه القمه
وبرغم من عقادها في اجواء مفعمه بالتحديات
والازمات
تؤشر لانخراط عربي اكبر في الازمات
والمشكلات
ولعلنا نلاحظ جميعا ان حضور الساده
الوزراء في هذا المجلس ربما يقترب من انه
كامل
ان العرب اكثر من اي طرف اخر هم من يدفع
ثمن استمرار الازمات وتعثر الحلول
واننا نتطلع جميعا الى قمه ناجحه باذن
الله
تكون عند مستوى تطلعات الراي العام وعلى
قدر التحديات القائمه
تقدم حلولا عربيه للمشكلات العربيه
وتعزز من قوه هذه الكتله الاقليميه
وتماسكها وتوحد كلماتها وعلى الله قصد
السبيل والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات